Louis Alvarez was an incredibly
brilliant scientist he realized that the
song called the inverse Square law which
is that the signal gets weaker not as
the distance away from it but it gets
diminished by the distance to the second
power meaning as you go away from
something the gravitational force that
you feel if I double the distance is
four times lower that's Newton's law of
gravity and a gravity force decreases as
inverse Square it also holds for radar
Reflections so Alvarez said I could
spoof the Germans by intentionally when
they send me a signal I'm going to send
them a signal when I'm coming closer to
them I'm going to take their signal I'm
going to diminish it I'm going to shoot
it back exactly as the inverse Square
because he knew how far away they were
too so he spoofed them and he
transmitted the signal so even though he
was getting closer they thought oh
nothing to worry about he's getting
farther away and then the planes would
blow up the radar sites and then they'd
be blind